>> DFB: San Francisco, weather.
>> Brady: Why don't you draw us the Golden Gate bridge?
>> DFB: [laughs] I ccan't draw!
>> Brady: C'mon give us the Golden Gate bridge!
>> DFB: Oh Lord! I'm running out of space look!
For the sake of argument we'll say there's only
four possibilities
It's sunny, cloudy, rainy or it's foggy.
And all you've got to say is: "OK what's the
probability of these are they equally
probable or is one more likely than the
other?" And for the sake of argument let's
say that in San Francisco - you do get all
of these - it's amazing - every single one in about
an equal proportion, roughly.
So let's say it's a quarter, and a
quarter, and a quarter, and a quarter. And all
those of you who have been through high school
statistics know, if these are
probabilities [you] add them all together.
It's got to add up to 1.  1 is certainty,
hundred percent. So four quarters is 1.
Let's say therefore that
here am I in San Francisco and here is
my friend in Reno.
>> Brady: In Reno !
>> DFB: And we have got
an electronic buzzer.
You know one of those old-fashioned
things that you see in wartime movies
where you tap out Morse code, or whatever.
But this is going to be very, very simple.
At an agreed time in the day
I've got to transmit the state of the
weather in San Francisco, from my weather
station to the guy in Reno as compactly as
possible. Because this is the early days
of electronic transmission and each bit costs
me a thousand dollars to send, OK [exaggeration!]
OK, so what's the minimum number of bits
I need, because when I'm going to encode it
in 0s and 1s.
Well, you look at this. There's four
states there, all
equally probable. How about something
like this 00 for Sunny,  01 for Cloudy, 10
for Rainy and 11 for Foggy. Four completely
separate, distinguishable, possibilities, Right?
So, if its sunny the guy here just goes
tap, tap, two short dots for two zeros and
the guy at Reno knows, for only two thousand
dollars,  that it's sunny at the weather
station in San Francisco.
Can you do any better than that?
No. You can't. You've got four equally
probable things.
There's no way in the world that,
losslessly, you can get better than that.
Yeah?! However ...
>> Brady: It sounds very defeatist!
>> DFB: Well, it is! But you asked, is there a limit?
And there is! Right? So long as you want it
lossless there is a limit and you can't
get below it. It's the entropy limit and
those who've done chemistry and physics
will know you can't beat it.
All right? However if only things were
more predictable -
this is not quite true but it's
virtually true - Sahara Desert.
>> Brady: I'm not going to ask you draw a picture
for that because there's no ....
>> DFB: Probability! The probability here is one
- it is always sunny in the Sahara Desert.
So if I've got my Sahara Desert
keypad here and have got a transatlantic line to
Reno, Nevada, where [let's say] they gather all
of this data,
How many bits of information do I need
to send to get that message
to Reno? The answer is, if the weather
never changes,
you don't need to send any information
at all! It's  always sunny!
Why ask? But if you want to be absolutely
sure let's just say: "Send a zero to be sure".
>> Brady: OK, so send a zero if it's sunny?
>> DFB: Send a zero if it's sunny. You didn't
really need to because it always is. That's cost you
... well probably cost you at least a thousand
dollars to send it again but, yeah, one bit.
One bit would be more than ample. Actually
the information theory answer is zero
bits, because if it's certain you don't
need to tell anybody!
This will kill you ... you can edit this
out. But you do the Maths ones don't you ?
>> Brady: We edit nothing out here!
Yeah! I do the Maths ones.
I do the Maths ones!
>> DFB: OK, so what we remember, of course, is
that 1/4 is the same as 1 over 2
squared, which is the same as 2 to the
power minus 2. Number of bits you need
equals probability of it happening.
times log of the probability of it happening
[with a minus sign].
If you take  log to the base 2, of 2 to the
minus 2, the answer is -2. Turn it positive: 2.
What the log of that probability is
telling you is the number of bits you
need [at the] minimum.
>> Brady: So there is, for any piece of information,
there's a minimum number of bits?
>> DFB: So if one of these was an 1/8th
how many bits would you need to encode it all?
>> Brady: Why don't you tell me ?!
>> DFB: Well I ... y'know ... If if there were eight things, right
then what you could say is that 2 to the
power minus 3 is 1/8, so it will be a
3-bit code.
>> Brady: Are you auditioning for a place
on "Numberphile" here aren't you, I can tell!
>> DFB: I don't know!
>> Brady: that's what happened back there, yeah.
We've got this minimum for this piece of information.
Is that only on the playing field
of the system we use at the moment -
these zeros and ones?  I mean is it
possible if we use - came up with - a new
way of storing and transmitting
information it would be a game changer?
Or is zeros and ones, you know ...
>> DFB: No, if we ... leaving aside weird quantum
effects - who knows what might come out of
that - as of the real world as we have it,
this is just .... it's a showstopper.
You can't get beyond
this entropy limit. When I was taught
about entropy - this irreversible sort of
minimum that you can get - when you do it
from the point of view of physics and
chemistry they love saying things like
this, and it sort of works. You've got
a diamond close to absolute zero,
yeah, that is a very low entropy system.
Low entropy means it is ultra-predictable.
There's the crystal it's vibrating but only
just. You know where it is - it's not moving.
High entropy is when the probabilities
are smeared out you don't know where it is.
So by the time you get a gas, with millions
of molecules zooming here there and everywhere
that's a very mixed, random, high entropy system
Now you can see how I take the view
that it's a lot easier, instead of starting
with 10 ^ 23 molecules in a gas,
start with four weather states in San
Francisco and you get the idea. And then
you can transfer it to physics and
chemistry and say Oh! well, in physics and chemistry
unfortunately, we've  got to use natural logs and
you've got to take a summation - not over
four states, right, but over 10 ^ 24.
Because, you see, here ...
>> Brady: I definitely can't figure that one out!
>> DFB: No here you can say average number of
bits I need is the sum over all these p log p's
So it's a quarter times two bits, for
that one, plus a quarter times two bits
plus a quarter times two bits plus a
quarter times two bits - wow isn't this amazing!
The answer is that the average message
length is two bits.
But if those were skewed a bit you can
kind of instinctely see what you
would do. If one of these became a half
you'd want to give it a short code? Right?
>> Brady: Because if it was
sunny more often
I would say: "Well let's make our code
for sunny short and some obscure
weather like a tornado, I'll make it  ....
>> DFB: Exactly! So like it was a half
your theory here would say,
that's 2 to the minus 1, hey, let's try
a 1-bit code there and let's use 2-bit
codes for the others.
So you could end up with something - if
it's like Los Angeles is reputed to be -
that's Smoggy and that's Sunny, that's Rain,
that's Cloud. What you could then start
saying: "Oh well, how about devoting the
code 0 to denoting smoggy, yeah?
>> Brady: Because its more common ?
>> DFB: Because its more common.
Anybody who's watched World War II
movies and people tapping out Morse
codes and a lot of people i'm sure we'll
know that the most common letter, 'e',  has
got the shortest code?
It's a single dot in Morse code,
whereas 'z' is quite long and so on.
So it applies, y'know,
all the way through this. So what you
could say, therefore, is: "If I'm
going to start with 0 for Smoggy
then I'd better not confuse matters by
starting a longer code for any of these
with 0". Right? Let's start them all with 1.
So let's say something like 10,
Sunny, but then you say: "Hmm! I'd better
not start either of these with 10, otherwise
things will get confused". So let's start them with 11
Yeah but the trouble is, if I use 11, I'm
then running out of what I can use for
Cloud. Can you see you'd have to say 110
and 111?k Because you've got to be able to
uniquely decode it. And if you're not
very careful you will end up with
something that can't be uniquely
unscrambled. Suppose to save telephone costs
you just sent a week's weather, all at once.
Seven things, one after another
How can you uniquely unscramble it
into being these .... yeah! it happens with
telephone numbers!
It happens to me at home. This, and my telephone
number, has to have the "prefix property".
I live in a village where my telephone
number is a five-digit code.
Unfortunately some people in the village
have got six-digit codes.
Yes, telephone codes have the prefix
property. They connect the moment they've
been unambiguously satisfied.
So, if you have a legal five-digit
telephone code
it cannot be the prefix of a longer code,
because the telephone exchange goes "bang!"
and connects you the moment you give it
something sensible.
Yeah, the trouble then is that the
Ocado delivery system doesn't
understand this and thinks everybody's got
to have six digits. So, do  you know what I do?
>> Brady: So when you're ordering groceries you
deliberately put a wrong number in ?!
>> DFB: Yes, at the very end
>> Brady: This might be a good tip for new
players. If smeone won't accept your
phone number just add any digits at the end
>> DFB: Just add any digits to the end.
>> Brady: If a weather condition was more
common, like sunny weather in California,
you give that a shorter code to
save information?
Did the people that invented the JPEG
format, or do other people that are doing
compression, use probabilities in the same way?
>> DFB: Oh yes!
>> Brady: So do they know that blue is more
common in pictures, or how do they use them?
>> DFB: No, it doesn't quite come down to that.
It's more - in the jJPEG standard that it's more,
as it were, spatially aware as well as
colour aware in terms of what it's doing.
But, yeah, in one respect or another
probabilities is at the root of all of
this and, like I say, that's particularly
true if you want lossless compression
because you run up against
unstoppable entropy limits about how far
you can compress and not lose anything
in in the compression.
>> Brady: Well I'm glad it's not my job to
compress this video!